is this the next Target for activists
two weeks until the royal family
descends here
and fears the glamor and Grandeur of raw
Ascot will be sabotaged heightened after
Saturday's Derby disruption
animal rights campaigners invading the
Epson track but not delaying racing as
they did at the Grand National my
concern is the
um protection of the people are
protesting if they are very close to
large numbers of people who are become
very angry at their actions uh then of
course we have to protect them as well
our main aim is to keep everything
unsafe to achieve that we're told the
latest Racecourse breach will see Royal
Ascot reassess their plans
scale of the security challenge here is
clear it's a vast Racecourse with low
fences and recent major disruption at
horse racing festivals just reinforces
the challenge for organizers
and racing isn't the only sport being
attacked by activists just stop all your
demonstrators cause this stoppage at the
world snooker championships in April
and the Environmental Group also blocked
the England men's Cricket team's journey
to Lords this week until the government
makes a statement that it will end new
oil and gas licenses we are looking at
everything non-violently
um reasonable and um and looking at all
kinds of civil resistance in order to
achieve that aim which is absolutely
fundamental to our survival
it's a warning with the ashes British
Grand Prix and Wimbledon coming up that
leaves event organizers with additional
security headaches we do a very thorough
threat and risk assessment and then our
Arrangements particularly for security
are planned around those and that's an
ever-changing environment as you rightly
identify there have been some incidents
recently that will inform the planning
that we will undertake across sport a
close eye to spot any threats not even
injunctions are deterring direct action
action activists say is vital to ensure
their causes and demands are heard even
if that means disrupting the sporting
summer Rob Harris Sky News ascot